okay we're gonna get back into some more
Doctor Who stuff I've already done a
little bit of ranking I rank the doctors
I'm now gonna do a ranking of companions
and a couple of things before I get
started firstly I'm only going to deal
with companions from the modern era of
Doctor Who starting with Christopher
Eccleston going forward if I were to do
classic companions this thing would be
an hour and a half long secondly I need
to clarify how I am choosing to define a
companion I have two requirements
firstly they have to appear in more than
one story and to be clear two parters
count as a single story that's the first
thing so that gets rid of any one-off
characters secondly we need to have seen
them be in the TARDIS for a trip with
those requirements that gives me 15 that
we got to be tackling here let's get
right into it starting with the bottom
of the barrel Angie and already I'm not
gonna spend a lot of time on these two
because I really wish I didn't even have
to deal with them but unfortunately they
meet the requirement they were just
horrible all they do is complain
secondly they do absolutely nothing to
move the plot forward you could
literally remove them from the plot
completely and almost nothing about the
story changes they are completely
useless moving on number fourteen Adam
Mitchell this guy's also completely
useless the difference though is he at
least was supposed to be completely
useless Adam Mitchell is a bad companion
by design he was written to be that way
so that it shows that rose Tyler's
ability to cope with everything that was
going on with being with the doctor was
not a universal gift a lot of people
can't cope going up slightly we get to
Jackie Tyler
now Jackie Kai was another one I kind of
wish I didn't have to deal with she
exemplifies the the whole domestic thing
there's almost been nothing brought to
the table with all the domestics all but
the family the brothers siblings parents
especially once or twice it was kind of
interesting because it was a side we
hadn't really seen before in the classic
series but it got old real quick and I
wish they would all just go away next on
the agenda Clara Oswald
I loved her chemistry with Matt Smith
but in truth she's a much better plot
point than she is a character she's very
very thinly drawn
I actually prefer her appearances in
asylum of the Daleks and the snowman I
feel like there was actually more depth
in those earlier incarnations than in
the woman the version of Clara that we
actually got to spend a lot more time
with she's getting a little bit better
now that the whole mystery of the
impossible girl has been addressed but
it still just she feels very flimsy to
me and that brings us to Brian Williams
Rory's father again he gets on the lower
end for being part of the whole domestic
thing he ranks higher than Jackie Tyler
though because he is inherently likable
Jackie Tyler is inherently grading he's
just a sweet guy and you get where a lot
of the things that are wonderful about
Rory come from so it's kind of a nice
insight but ultimately I can take them
or leave them that brings us to number
10 the last of the double digits and I
got to be really careful on how I
explain this one because I'm going to
get a lot of heat for it Sarah Jane
Smith I made the decision to only take
into consideration modern-era main show
appearances I am NOT considering any of
her work in the classic era nor am i
considering it anything that she
appeared in in spin-offs she's a piece
of nostalgia brilliantly executed
nostalgia don't do not get me wrong but
her peak as a companion was in the
classic era especially when she was
paired with Tom Baker now I mean she's
nice it's nice to have her there but she
doesn't bring as much to the proceedings
beyond just a sort of oh cool check it
out thing that oh I feel the ones I've
ranked above her they just bring more to
the table in their appearances in the
modern era number 9 Martha Jones
she's the rebound companion we know it
the doctor knows it ultimately Martha
knows it I can certainly appreciate and
respect her as a character but in the
scope of the doctor she's always gonna
be middling to lower-ranking just
because of where she came in in his time
stream
yeah that's just gonna be the way it is
number 8 Mickey Smith
and Mickey was interesting because the
journey he went through Mickey when he
started out was kind of annoying he was
almost as bad as Jackie and his early
appearances but he went through a
transformation and a journey through his
experiences that by the end not only is
are you happy to see him when he turns
up but he's turned into a badass and
it's all very believable we get it in
these little measured doses and you can
see the change happening I think we got
just enough Mickey Smith to make that
transformation believable too much more
of him would have gotten old I think he
was very well balanced number 7 Rose
Tyler
I do like Rose Tyler I was never as
enamored with her as some people wore
just because she did well she did some
stupid stuff for no reason other than to
kind of show how the doctor deals with
people when they do stupid things
she still wonderfully charming she's a
lot of fun definitely Billie Piper
really brought that to the rule and that
is really what carries her through on
paper she wavers a little bit you put
her in Billy Piper's hands and she
brings a charm to the whole thing that
actually makes it work number six Jack
Harkness now again remember I'm not
taking spin-off material into
consideration here which unlike Sarah
Jane Smith is actually in Jack Harkness
is favored because I don't particularly
like what they do with him and Torchwood
they make him into this very tortured
hour figure where what's great about him
in the main series is how fun he is he's
he's definitely at his best when he's
playing alongside Christopher Eccleston
because he brings something to the
proceedings that Christopher Eccleston
just doesn't have the more dashing
heroic hey kind of character now he
doesn't work quite as well when he's
with David Tennant cuz David Tennant has
that same thing going on so he Jack
becomes a little bit redundant but he's
still fun to have around and every time
he turns up it makes me smile
number five Rory Williams here was
another one that a bit like Mickey we
get the boyfriend who is annoying at
first but then he goes through a whole
journey and a transformation and with
Rory oh my god by the end I just I loved
him you get to know his relationship
with Amy he's kind of her punching bag a
little bit you think oh that's sweet but
sad
but then once amy comes to appreciate
him and you see the lengths that he goes
through to be with her it's wonderful
and the two of them together are just
dynamite and even rory when interacting
directly with the doctor is great when
he punches the doctor or when he
confronts the Cybermen where is my wife
oh it's it's fantastic stuff and when
he's put into conflict because of Amy
you get the best out of it number four
the always controversial river song I
love the very concept of her that she
meets the doctor completely out of order
but we never feel like we know her
enough that we can completely trust her
you always feel like she's pulling one
over on the doctor and pulling one over
on us as an audience and I kind of like
that feeling personally I guess it bugs
some people but I think she's a lot of
fun and I regret that we have probably
seen the end of her at this point pretty
much everything about her has gotten
tied up by now with the exception of
exactly how she learned the doctor's
name which still bugs me that that
hasn't been addressed but I may just
have to deal with it number three
Amy Pond now I love the way the doctor
meets Amy Pond I love the way that their
relationship develops because the fact
that she was enamored with him as a
child
but also that he abandoned her really
informs their relationship because she
is astounded by him and in awe of him
but at the same time kind of fed up with
him and she doesn't take any of his crap
I love their dynamic and she's even
better when paired with Rory the three
of them together the doctor Rory Amy I
just love that trio number two Wilfred
mops I love this guy and I really really
wish he could have been a longer term
companion Bernard Cribbins has this
feistiness to him that's just perfect to
pair him with someone who is physically
young but much much older the two of
them together the dynamic is so
wonderful it's so good and he breaks my
heart when he tries to give the doctor
the gun on the ship of the doctor one
take it he is so good and he's wonderful
and he's funny and he's sad and he's
almost everything I wanted my companion
not quite though because he didn't get
the top spot top spot goes to Donna
Noble she is the best friend the
romantic angle has been overplayed
severely just so sick of it Donna never
a question there was never even a hint
or an inkling in fact her outright
disgust at the very suggestion of
romantic involvement of the doctor
coupled with a wonderful chemistry and
the fact that like Amy she's able to
call him out on stuff and then just her
energy fact that she's a little bit
older that makes a lot of difference
everything that Catherine Tate is able
to bring to this role and when she's
working with David Tennant it's just
they bounce off each other in the best
possible way because she thinks about
things in a different way from the
doctor she has a much more blunt
approach to thing and that contrasts
with his more nuanced and finesse way of
going at things and thinking about him
and it's great just to see him bounce
off each other and then for them to come
together and work together it's always
fantastic stuff at every moment and then
what happens to her it hurts and it's
painful in the most beautiful way that
those sorts of things can be painful and
she takes the number one spot so there
we have it the companions of the doctor
ranks from the bottom of the barrel why
did they even show up to the very top
why can't they just travel in the TARDIS
forever I like to think that I justified
my ranking but you know what if you got
a different favorite than mine good for
you you should everybody's got their
favorites that's the beauty of Doctor
Who it's always changing it's always
renewing this why we love it and that's
why I cannot wait till we get more I
need to see Peter Capaldi and what he's
gonna do it's gonna be a long wait it'll
be worth it and until then this
council's adjourned